salut c'est monsieur grrrr aujourd'hui
on va parler d'un smartphone qui
pourrait bien changer la face de tous
les smartphones
on oublie les encoches on oublie les
dents noires sur l'eau et sur le bas on
réinvente un peu tout ça on a une caméra
amovible et ça c'est le vivent onex et
je vous en parle
[Musique]
vous avez déjà peut-être entendu parler
vivo vivo qui est un constructeur
chinois a annoncé la venue d'un tout
nouveau smartphone qui s'appelle le nex
on en a déjà entendu parler ya pas très
longtemps à l'occasion du mwc à
barcelone vous avez présenté un concept
phone c'est l apex lapègue c'est
effectivement un smartphone avec un très
grand écran et une caméra amovible 7
apex voit le jour sous le nom nex et
franchement franchement il pourrait
ouvrir une nouvelle voie dans l'ère des
smartphones pour une fois le terme
révolution serait pas trop galvaudé on
pourrait effectivement parler d'une
petite révolution
et c'est plutôt intéressant je vous fais
portrait-robot imaginer un smartphone
sans bords sur le haut sur le bas sans
caméra sans haut parleur avec à l'avant
uniquement un écran qu'un écran une
toute petite bordure sur le bord mais
vraiment c'est très très très léger pas
d'appareil photo pas de haut parleurs
pas de capteur de proximité fadin trois
rouges
rien du tout pas de faith ideapad en
cochant france ça n'existe pas vous ne
l'auriez pas du tout sur l'appareil
en plus de ça clou du spectacle sur les
32 d'avoir directement un capteur
d'empreintes digitales
vous allez pouvoir positionner votre
doigt directement dessus et paf ça va
déverrouiller et c'est justement ça que
propose le vivent onex c'est à dire un
smartphone qui sort un peu des sentiers
battus qui est un design change
complètement par rapport à l'ensemble de
l'offre de smartphones qu'on peut
trouver sur le marché et surtout qui a
une caméra escamotable et lorsque vous
actionnez vous avez une petite caméra
qui sort du coup ça vous fait un design
qui est complètement repensé par rapport
à ce que vous avez sur le marché
actuellement
du point de vue de la fiche technique
vous avez un écran de 6,59 pouces super
amoled fhd plus haut ratio 19,3 ne
vienne un écran qui occupent 91,24 % de
la face avant
c'est à dire quasiment l'ensemble de la
face avant est occupée par l'écran on
trouve en plus des nouvelles techno
c'est à dire déverrouiller son écran
directement avec capteur d'empreintes
digitales positionner sur l'écran ce qui
est super intéressant c'est cette
fameuse caméra de celle fille qui est
complètement escamotable vous avez tous
le module photo qui ressort dieu de
l'appareil pour vous prendre en photo et
lorsque vous avez pas besoin
elle va rentrer à l'intérieur une caméra
de 8 mégapixels avec une ouverture de f
2.0
l'autre point qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est fait vous n'avez pas
de haut parleurs normalement votre
prochain smartphone
quel que soit le smartphone voulu
positionner là vous avez votre haut
parleurs là et forcément on pouvait
entendre vous mettez sur notre oreille
voilà je vous faire un truc hyper vas-y
qu'il nous propose
un groupe sait comment ça marche vous
parlez non rassurez vous sauf que là
c'est vraiment différent la technologie
s'appelle la screen sand casting
technologie c'est à dire qu'en fait le
son provient de l'écran j'imagine que
l'écran va propager le sont pour vous
puissiez entendre directement net vous
avez posé votre smartphone sur votre
oreille alors qu'en fait aucun haut
parleurs qui veut dire correspondre à
l'entrée de votre oreille ça c'est une
techno qu'on avait déjà retrouvé à
quelque temps chez xiaomi mais qui a été
abandonné par la marque avoir néanmoins
à ce que ça va donner sur seulles vive
onex il vous annonce au siècle cette
techno un son de meilleure qualité plus
de base des médiums plus précis bon ça
faut le voir lors d'un test à l'arrière
ya quand même un petit peu moins de
surprises vous êtes un module photo avec
un double capteur 12 mégapixels 5
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 1.8
vous avez en réalité deux modèles le nex
et nex ultimate le nex vous est proposé
avec un qualcomm snapdragon 710 cadencé
à 2,2 ghz
si giga de ram et 128 go de stockage
tandis que le nex ultimate vous est
proposé avec un qualcomm snapdragon 845
8 gigas de ram et 256 go de stockage et
la puce graphique c'est une adreno 630
vous avez une batterie de 4000 millan
paire eur la connectique celle usb type
c du bluetooth 5.0 et une prise jack
au niveau de l'oreille vous avez une
surcouche funtouch os 4.0 qui est basé
sur un android ou huit points auraient
au point de vue logiciel vous avez de
l'intelligence artificielle c'est à dire
de la reconnaissance de scène
reconnaissance du visage
optimisation de la luminosité
optimisation des couleurs par rapport à
ce que vous allez voir photographié il
ya aussi du hdr différents filtres on va
pas mal de choses de ce point de vue là
il ya aussi un assistant vocal pour
l'intelligence artificielle qui
s'appelle jovi jovi c'est marrant ça
fait penser à quelque chose ça bon trêve
de blague
pas sûr qu'on retrouve traduit dans la
langue de molière vous avez la peau cité
d'avoir une double carte sim et surtout
pour l'instant c'est un produit qui ne
sera disponible qu'en chine pour
l'instant pas lu toute sortie annoncée
en europe aux états-unis nulle part
peut-être que singapour laura le japon
on sait pas non plus affaire à suivre
côté tarif vous donner l'équivalent en
euros cantonné les tarifs en gagnent
pour avoir le vivent onex avec le cendre
agon 710 il vous en coûtera 515 euros
hors taxes et si vous voulez la grande
configuration le nex ultimate avec le
qualcomm snapdragon 845 ça nous coûtera
595 euros hors taxes sur le papier en
photo je trouve hyper séduisant cette
marque run on va pas se mentir l'idée
de pouvoir avoir enfin un vrai grand
écran sans encoches son trousseau chose
perforé c'est pas mal maintenant je les
petits crainte un petit craintes déjà au
niveau de la caméra escamotable des
corps ajoute une partie mécanique chose
qui va bouger toujours des craintes
d'avoir soit d'ehpad soit de
l'endommager l'endommager si vous la
faites tomber vous la fait tomber sur le
mauvais angle directement sur la caméra
est ce qu'à ce moment là vous risquez
pas de la casse et lui donner un billet
c'est complètement possible ce que vaut
ce qui est passé d'abord des pannes ne
soit plus qu'un moment à la caméra ne
monte plus ne descendent plus voilà ça
c'est toujours un petit peu le truc qui
me pose question dès lors qu'on va
rajouter un tiroir mécanique sur un
objet est là sur un smartphone vu que
c'est miniaturisés voilà ça c'est
vraiment le point d'interrogation
deuxième point d'interrogation c'est
l'audio vu que vous n'avez plus de haut
parleurs vous à vannes audio directement
via votre écran est ce que cette
technologie va vraiment être
intéressante
est ce que les personnes qui seront
autour de vous ne risquez pas d'entendre
votre corps astraux téléphoniques et
assister au lynchage de votre compagne
votre compagnon à votre liste de courses
à des infos confidentielles pour travail
c'est toujours un petit peu pas y avoir
l'an ii phase de test au niveau de la
fiche technique mise à part la puissance
qui est vraiment intéressant sur le nex
ultimate je trouve qu'il est par le
cendre agon 710 why not 1845 très bien
côté photo ça peut être sympa mais je
suis pas sûr que ce soit là dessus que
c'est vraiment le plus fort on a une
batterie tapis millan période ont
probablement une bonne autonomie voire
un petit peu maintenant comment tout ça
est fait d'un point de vue logiciel qui
a bien trois choses à retenir c'est déjà
l'écran le grand écran sans perforation
sans encoches sans rien du tout ça pour
le coup c'est vraiment révolutionnaire
le deuxième point c'est la caméra
escamotable même s'il ya des doutes sur
le fait que ce soit robuste solide et
que ça dure dans le temps c'est quand
même quelque chose qui va dans le bon
sens pouvoir essayer d'autres solutions
c'est super intéressant
et le troisième point le fait de pas
voir de haut parleurs même si je ne sais
pas que donner réellement cette
technologie s'avère intéressante vu
qu'elle était abandonné par shiomi
est-ce que vivo va le voir un petit peu
mieux réussies et mieux intégrée à son
appareil pour le coup vivo prend des
risques et ça a un petit peu des
nouvelles chansons ses smartphones et ça
s'est plutôt bien passé sur que ce
smartphone on est un jour entre nos
mains pour l'instant est réservé
exclusivement au marché chinois
peut-être qu'on pourra la voir en import
notamment par des sites comme 10rbs
affaire à suivre tout cas si on peut se
le procurer je vous en parlais très très
prochainement
parce que sur le papier je trouve que
c'est vraiment intéressante époque où il
ya vraiment un produit qui est novateur
il ya vraiment une marque qui essaye des
choses et ça c'est plutôt bien
maintenant vous dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez qu est ce que vous pensez
de ce smartphone avec ce grand écran
sans encoches sans rien du tout est ce
que vous trouvez ça intéressant est ce
que l'idée d'avoir un capteur
d'empreintes digitales positionner sur
l'écran
peut vous intéresser vous voyez
l'utilité d'en avoir un au dos est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est pour jouer la
sécurité
ça c'est le point d'interrogation est ce
que vous avez des doutes comme moi sur
la caméra escamotable pas tant des
risques de malfaçons mais surtout qu'à
un moment ça fonctionne un petit peu mal
et surtout au niveau du haut parleur est
ce que vous connaissez déjà cette techno
et si oui qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
vous marquez tout ça en commentaire je
vous invite bien évidemment comme
d'habitude elle décédée je les pousse à
vous abonner lorsqu'on parlait encore
plus de take 2 produits innovants il ya
plein de choses plein de tests et plein
de surprises qui arrive et même des
cadeaux vous en dit pas plus au moment
reste à collecter abonnez vous et à très
bientôt
[Musique]